[Music]
thanks for joining us America we're glad
you're here so it's all over the news
feeds today I started seeing it early
this morning when I was in the gym on
Nordstrom's
selling four hundred and twenty-five
dollar blue jeans that have built in
dirt they look like you were working and
got dirty and it doesn't wash out I mean
it looks like I mean I when I was in
high school I used to do a bunch of
miscellaneous odds-and-ends repairs and
you know crawling around under a house
and hooking a pipe back up some guy
busted a pipe or something or that kind
of thing and you come out you know you
come out from in our house have you been
crawling in a crawl space you just your
jeans are just shot you know they're
just covered in dirt that's what these
jeans look like for $425 you have to
stop and think about what the socio
psychological implications are of a
we've reached a point in the culture
where we at Meijer work enough to look
like we did it but we didn't and be it's
a fashion statement to the tune of a
Nordstrom's jeans for $425 I don't think
I've ever paid I don't know what I paid
for jeans because sometimes they've been
bought for me when we were doing like a
photo shoot or something but I'm pretty
sure we never paid anywhere near that
for any jeans I wear jeans every day Ken
Coleman you never did pay that much for
jeans video I'm looking at Ken out
though he's our video host and
occasional host here on the show as well
I mean he's mr. clothing too I mean he's
a he's a button-up dapper kind of guy
but he never paid 400 a quarter but he
wouldn't be caught dead in jeans that
looked dirty either yeah that wouldn't
happen so
mmm James child you wouldn't wear dirty
jeans would you not to work probably not
it doesn t real dirt if it was now I
mean that might be you know we talked
about hipsters the other day that our
twits and then we call them twisters
that might be at you if you wear dirty
jeans that aren't really dirty but we're
made to look dirty and you paid four
hundred twenty-five dollars one you
might be a twister that might be a sign
right there it's just interesting it's
kind of disgusting in a lot of ways if
we're in twenty five dollar jeans if you
want to buy them in your billionaire
it's okay I'm not mad at you but I it's
just an interesting thing that somebody
thought that that and it's getting a lot
of press so Nora's got a lot of I mean
I've seen it in like five different news
feeds already today its Nordstrom got a
lot of lift out of it so if it was a PR
stunt it worked but uh it's just
interesting that you know you think
about a culture who's willing to pay
money to look like they've worked when
they didn't even know what work was I
mean I saw one guy tweeted boy I've had
like six people tweeted to me today too
everybody wants me to rant on this and I
don't know if it's a rant but I kind of
had that German Shepherd moment you know
when your dog looks at you in their head
goes sideways you go mm-hmm that's kind
of what I went really for and $29 for
dirty jeans aren't really dirty but
won't wash out the one guy he tweeted
and said yeah I'll sell you mine for
half that and they were done West Texas
oil field or something
Kansas oil field or wherever he was he
said he was working it's like real work
and a real guy did it but these look
legit I mean they look like the pictures
I saw him look like somebody really did
do the work someone is really working
and but it's an interesting dichotomy we
admire the working man quote unquote to
the point that we want to emulate him
and make it a fashion statement and yet
we all know the likelihood of the person
wearing those jeans has never been that
dirty lately and that would include me
if I were to buy though I mean I don't
wallow around in the dirt anymore I've
done it before I'm not above doing it
but pretty much going to hire somebody
else to do that these days come on I
mean really I mean there's guys above my
house doing work today and I know how to
swing that hammer too but I'm not the
one swinging it you know so I'm pretty
much work so I don't have to do that but
you know it's interesting it's
interesting how we I wonder what the
there's probably some conclusions as
someone smarter than me could come to
about the American psyche and I mean a
lot of people are just throwing it down
as it's a you know you know the wood
suffocation of America is now complete
we now buy jeans they're dirty but I
said that when we bought jeans that had
holes in them I was a kid we used to put
patches over the holes because we were
ashamed we had holes in our clothes and
now of course you razor cut them to look
cool or worse than that some of you to
look sexy that wouldn't work with me but
take more than razor cut jeans to pull
that off but I'm interesting very
interesting that dirty jeans that look
like you did work that won't wash out
for $425 at Nordstrom's is a thing I
give you a prediction it's a PR PR thing
I mean they'll get some PR I don't think
it'll catch on but here's how this is
Dave's fashion advice which is really
pretty that's like me talking about
growing hair so kind of dumb but um now
I I'm thinking I didn't think the cut
jeans would the holey jeans would work
either but they did they've kind of gone
away now haven't they pretty well
there's a few people still doing that
I'll see as many as I used to two years
ago three years ago most people's jeans
are pretty much the whole thing
interesting very interesting
what dead-stick is the one look you know
they look like the one you know all of
us wear jeans now the ones I got on
right now not they don't look like
they're new in their new so I'm no that
did stick because when we're kids we
just bought blue jeans and you know by
the time they started looking a little
more light blue rather than dark blue
that meant they'd been worn a while that
was only way you got them there you
couldn't
by them I remember gosh I was in high
school had stone washed jeans or
something that came out wow that's cool
look I could read even warring I guess
this could be the same thing it could be
20 years from now everybody wearing
jeans would look like they're in a dirt
it's just bizarre just bizarre one who
sat around and thought of that if they
sell I have to stop I have to give pause
and go what does that say about where we
are right now in this culture that
you're willing to pay $425 for jeans
that look like you worked when know
everyone watching you knows you didn't
do that work and you paid a premium to
do that to buy them in a fashion outlet
like Nordstrom's because Nordstrom's is
pretty much high fashioned
stuff I mean it's not like regular
people shopping you know unless you go
to the outlet but um you know
interesting very interesting so we'll
just have to see I guess we'll see how
this catches on hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]